Eddie Brock and Venom are back for the sequel
to the 2018 hit about the symbiotic antihero,
and like Cletus Kasady promised, there's gonna
be carnage.
Here's everything you might have missed in
the ultra-violent first trailer for "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage."
We've known for a while that Woody Harrelson
would bring Cletus Kasady to life in "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage," following up the cameo
appearance he made at the end of the first
film.
The trailer indicates that he's going to be
quite the formidable opponent for the film's
titular anti-hero, as it teases a big showdown
between the pair, and it's safe to assume
that much scenery will be chewed in the process.
In the comics, Eddie Brock and Cletus Kasady
have a history with one another.
First introduced in 1991's "The Amazing Spider-Man"
344, Kasady is a sociopathic serial killer
who becomes the host for Carnage, an alien
symbiote who's much nastier than Venom.
Due to Kasady's lack of moral compass as a
human, things get even worse when Carnage
is part of the equation.
Together, the pair have been guilty of some
pretty heinous crimes throughout the years.
Kasady is depicted as somewhat of a sympathetic
character in the Marvel comics, as he had
a tough upbringing courtesy of his abusive
mother and grandmother.
It will be interesting to see how "Let There
Be Carnage" explores his troubled backstory
and his connection to Eddie.
The trailer for "Let There Be Carnage" offers
a brief look at the entrance to the Ravencroft
Institute for the Criminally Insane, where
Cletus Kasady is being held.
The notorious supervillain was actually born
in the asylum to his mother Louise Kasady,
as explained in 2018's "Web of Venom: Carnage
Born" 1.
Kasady finds himself back at his birthplace
after he's captured for heinous crimes.
There, he meets his love interest Shriek,
aka Frances Barrison, who also makes a brief
appearance in the trailer — but more on
her later.
In the Marvel comics, Kasady's actions lead
to the destruction of Ravencroft, which appears
to happen in the trailer as well.
It looks like Kasady is going to be executed
by lethal injection, but something goes wrong,
as Kasady is screaming in pain and the windows
of the room he's being held in shatter.
The trailer then cuts to show a massive building
up in flames, and we're led to believe this
is Ravencroft.
As it happens, there's comic book precedence
for this incident.
Famous Marvel villain Wilson Fisk funds the
cleanup of the asylum in 2020's "Ruins of
Ravencroft" 1, but there's some interference
from Reed Richards, aka Mr. Fantastic, of
the Fantastic Four.
Richards wants to ensure that the new facility
is going to be used properly, and is a thorn
in Fisk's side.
In "Ravencroft" 1, the Daredevil villain hires
Norman Osborn and other famous Marvel baddies
to work in the resurrected asylum.
Marvel fans have long known how important
"The Daily Bugle" is in the sprawling world
of Spider-Man, and since both Venom and Carnage
are established Spidey villains in the comics,
it's fitting that "Venom: Let There Be Carnage"
reference the newspaper-turned-online-outlet.
In the trailer, Eddie visits the "Daily Bugle"
website, and in the next scene, Detective
Mulligan is reading a hard copy of the “West
Coast Edition” of the newspaper.
In the comics, both Eddie and Peter Parker
work for newspapers.
In fact, Eddie sees Peter as a rival, which
leads to him becoming one of Spider-Man's
most dangerous enemies when he inherits the
Venom symbiote.
While "The Daily Bugle" played a key role
in Sam Raimi's Spider-Man movies, the only
major "Daily Bugle" moment in the Tom Holland
movies occurred at the end of "Spider-Man:
Far From Home," when the paper's editor, J.
Jonah Jameson, released a video revealing
Peter's secret identity.
These two references in the trailer make it
clear that the newspaper is part of the "Venom"
franchise just as it is in the "Spider-Man"
films, but that doesn't mean all the characters
are aware of one another's existence.
Director Andy Serkis told IGN that Eddie is,
quote, “unaware at this point of other characters
like Spider-Man.”
Serkis explained,
"Obviously, there are links between Venom
and Spider-Man in the Marvel Universe and
the Spider-Man story, but in this, we're treating
this very much as it's his own world, the
Venom story is his own world.”
In the trailer, we see Detective Mulligan
reading "The Daily Bugle," with a headline
that highlights Cletus Kasady's "hidden victims."
While Mulligan may seem like your typical
detective whose primary goal is to get justice
for Kasady's victims and lock up the villain
for life, there might be more to him than
meets the eye.
In the pages of Marvel Comics, there's a character
named Patrick Mulligan, who works as a police
officer and ends up becoming the host for
the terrifying symbiote Toxin, which has all
of Venom and Carnage's powers but heightened
to a greater degree.
Could we see Toxin bind to Detective Mulligan
in "Venom 2"?
Never say never.
Watch carefully as Mulligan shuts the newspaper,
and you'll spot a headline on another page
that seemingly reads, "Avengers Lose to Nightmare."
This could be a blanket statement or an incomplete
headline — the Avengers have lost a battle
to a nightmarish villain, or they lost in
a nightmare of a situation — be a nod to
the Marvel Comics supervillain Nightmare,
who might play a part in "Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness."
Now, behind Mulligan in this specific shot
is a wanted poster for a man named E. Larson.
Erik Larsen, spelled with an "E" instead of
an "O," is a popular name in Marvel Comics
and has strong ties to Spider-Man.
The author, publisher, and artist's first
big works for Marvel came with 1990's "The
Amazing Spider-Man" 239, for which he designed
the cover art.
A year later, in 1991, Larsen created the
character of Cletus Kasady in "The Amazing
Spider-Man" 344.
The wanted poster in the trailer appears to
be a nod to the former Marvel writer, and
the intentional misspelling of his name might
either be Sony Pictures' way of throwing a
little bit of shade at Larsen or making the
reference a bit less obvious.
Larsen left Marvel Comics in 1992 to create
the comic book publishing company Image Comics.
Still alive and well today, Image Comics is
the publisher behind “Spawn,” "The Walking
Dead," "Invincible," and "Kick-Ass."
Other former Marvel names who left with Larsen
include Todd McFarlane and Rob Liefield, who
co-created Deadpool and Cable.
In the trailer for "Venom: Let There Be Carnage,"
we see Cletus Kasady in what appears to be
his prison cell, writing on a postcard.
This postcard appears to be similar to one
we see Eddie holding while he sits down to
eat breakfast at the beginning of the trailer.
The postcards we see are covered with drawings
and dense writing, which might provide an
unsettling glimpse inside the mind of Cletus
Kasady before he even escapes from prison.
After the post-credits scene of the first
"Venom" movie, did Kasady and Brock become
pen pals?
What exactly does Kasady have to say?
Will these handwritten exchanges kick off
a kind of cat-and-mouse game between Eddie
and Kasady, where the latter torments the
former from afar until they finally meet in
person again?
We'll have to wait to know all the details.
At one point in the "Venom" sequel's first
trailer, right after an offscreen Kasady says
how the people who are left behind are "waiting
in the darkness for the rescuer who never
comes," we see him smash the spider that crawls
across his postcard, killing it instantly.
This spider-crushing moment is a clear reference
to the fact that both Carnage and Venom are
villains of New York's own friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man.
Though Venom aims to fight evil, he's still
a monster.
But Kasady, however, is much more menacing
when infected with a symbiote, becoming Carnage,
a monster with no moral compass.
The main difference between Carnage and Venom
as Spider-Man villains is that Venom, while
often an antagonist to Spider-Man, has also
teamed up with the heroic web-slinger.
Carnage is an absolute villain who's stronger
than both Venom and Spider-Man, and because
he's taken over the serial killer Kasady,
he has no love for Spider-Man, hence the smashing.
At a couple of points in the "Venom: Let There
Be Carnage" trailer, viewers may see a familiar
face: British actress Naomie Harris, perhaps
most famously associated with the role of
Eve Moneypenny in the James Bond movies "Skyfall"
and "Spectre."
In the "Venom" sequel, Harris is taking the
role of Shriek, who's historically Cletus
Kasady's love interest.
Toward the middle of the trailer, we see Harris'
character lying down on her right side, with
a glimpse of her face revealing what appear
to be scars over her left eye.
These scars seem to match up with the facial
marking that Shriek's human alter-ego Frances
Barrison is known to have in the pages of
Marvel Comics.
In Marvel canon, Barrison is Kasady's fellow
patient at the Ravencroft Institute for the
Criminally Insane, and he frees her when he
escapes the mental institute.
In the trailer, two figures can be seen walking
away from a blazing structure, suggesting
that Kasady does destroy Ravencroft in the
"Venom" sequel, and that somebody leaves with
him when he does.
Later on in the trailer, we see Harris' character
in a holding cell, kneeling on the floor with
her head tilted back and letting out a high-pitched
cry that could most aptly be described as
a shriek.
We don't know for certain at this point whether
Kasady and Barrison will be a couple, but
Andy Serkis did note that Barrison is just
as dangerous as her counterpart.
The director told IGN,
"She's a damaged soul, and she really has
suffered in her childhood, but there is a
real vulnerability about her, and she's in
a lot of pain.
She's been living in isolation for years — years
and years."
The filmmaker also referred to the character's
twisted moral code, saying,
"She has her own sense of fairness and when
that line is crossed, then you see a very,
very dangerous, dark side to her, and that's
what we wanted to do with the character."
Whether you're addicted to smoking cigarettes
or eating people alive, it can be hard to
kick old habits.
And it definitely helps to have a safety net
— something to take the edge off those sharp
turns on the road to becoming a better you.
The trailer for "Venom: Let There Be Carnage"
calls back to one of Venom's more peculiar
cessation aids.
In the '90s Marvel Comics miniseries "Venom:
The Hunger," readers learn that the Venom
symbiote has a doozy of a monkey on its back:
He's addicted to consuming human brains.
Why brains?
"Hungry."
"Whoa, god damn."
Among other things, human brains produce a
chemical called phenethylamine, which Venom
had been milking from Eddie Brock's brain
for years, leaving it dried up.
A few issues of extreme shenanigans later,
and Eddie and Venom symbiote realize that
they could get the same sweet phenethylamine
rush from a bar of delicious chocolate.
The trailer for "Venom: Let There Be Carnage"
shouts out to this storyline in a couple of
ways.
First, Eddie posts around his apartment helpful
reminders to not eat anybody.
Then, in the final moments of the trailer,
Mrs. Chen, the protection racket she was running
in the first film now firmly on the other
foot, says she doesn't have the Wonka-licious
brain substitute that Venom so desperately
needs -- so Venom just brings up the idea
of eating her instead.
"The chocolate delivery hasn’t arrived yet"
NO!"
"We had a deal"
"You gonna stop protecting me?"
"I am happy to EAT Mrs. Chen"
"No, no, you can not EAT Mrs. Chen."
It's a silly note to end the trailer on, but
then again, isn't that part of what makes
the "Venom" franchise so much fun?
"Venom: Let There Be Carnage" is set to open
in theaters on September 24.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.